chers collègues bonjour à toutes et à
tous notre commission est saisie du
projet de loi portant en mesure
d'urgence pour adapter les dispositions
du code du commerce relative au
négociations commerciales dans la grande
distribution
nous avons désigné monsieur alexisard
pour rapporter ce texte bonjour monsieur
rapporteur et je salue également madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des PME du Commerce et de l'Artisanat et
du Tourisme bienvenue à Madame la
Ministre merci d'être avec nous
vous le savez dans notre pays et c'est
une spécificité française la législation
encadre les négociations entre les
distributeurs et les fournisseurs avec
une date annuelle qui est inscrite dans
la loi et donc la distribution et les
industriels doivent négocier une fois
par an à la même date qui est inscrite
donc dans notre législation le
gouvernement souhaite avec ce projet de
loi avancer et réduire pour l'année à
venir les dates des négociations entre
les distributeurs et les plus gros
industriels pour quelle raison parce que
c'est l'argument qui est évoqué depuis
les dernières négociations annuelles du
1er mars dernier des baisses ont été
constatées sur plusieurs matières
premières et plusieurs coûts de
production des fournisseurs et donc le
gouvernement propose à notre commission
à notre assemblée que le consommateur
puisse voir les effets de ces baisses
sur le ticket de caisse sans attendre
les prochaines négociations du 1er mars
2024 et en procédant donc à une
réduction et un avancement des dates de
négociation nous avons eu le temps de
discuter de ce sujet là lors des deux
tables rondes que nous avons organisés
en commission le 20 septembre dernier
qui regroupait pour la première table
ronde des quatre principaux
représentants de la grande distribution
et pour la seconde table ronde 4
organisations représentant l'industrie
agroalimentaire notre cher rapporteur a
ensuite organisé une vingtaine
d'auditions la semaine dernière auquel
chacun d'entre vous a pu participer je
salue les collègues qui ont participé
j'ai moi-même participé à certaines
d'entre elles et nous avons pu entendre
un certain nombre d'acteurs qui étaient
enthousiastes à l'idée de pouvoir
renégocier et qui nous disait
potentiellement réussir à obtenir des
baisses pour les consommateurs vous
n'oublierez monsieur le rapporteur tout
à l'heure et tant mieux pour le
consommateur si ça fonctionne au-delà de
cette intention louable pour faire
baisser les prix du caddie à court terme
un sujet plus structurel me taraude et
je me permettais de l'évoquer en
introduction si nous sommes amenés à
légiférer pour changer légal de
négociation entre les acteurs c'est
qu'il est peut-être temps Madame la
Ministre et chers collègues de se poser
la question de la pertinence de
l'inscription d'une telle date dans la
loi parce que nous n'allons pas en tout
cas je pense légiférer chaque année soit
pour avancer la date légale s'il y a une
chance de baisser les prix ou retarder
la date légale s'il y a un risque de
hausse des prix et donc il est peut-être
temps mais c'est une question que nous
pouvons débattre ensemble de donner un
peu plus de flexibilité aux acteurs dans
les années qui viennent de façon un peu
plus structurelle pour qu'il décide
contractuellement entre eux les
prochaines dates de négociation qu'ils
auront librement choisies il est
peut-être temps mais je conçois bien sûr
tout à fait que tout le monde ne soit
pas parfaitement aligné sur le sujet qui
faille concerté prendre le temps avant
de libérer un peu plus les négociations
commerciales en tout cas je me permets
de lancer ce débat à 10 d'introduction
et je suis sûr que on en discutera tout
à l'heure je referme la parenthèse je
reviens aux amendements je précise que
81 amendement ont été déposés sur ce
projet de loi quatre d'entre eux ont été
retirés par leurs auteurs un constituer
une charge en l'application de l'article
et deux amendements ne pouvaient figurer
dans une loi par ailleurs comme
d'habitude j'ai vérifié avec une grande
attention l'existence d'un lien direct
ou indirect des amendements avec les
dispositions du texte en l'espèce avec
le contenu de l'article unique étant
rappelé que le titre du projet de loi
n'est pas un critère d'appréciation du
lien direct ou indirect les dispositions
de l'article unique portant sur
l'encadrement temporel des négociations
commerciales j'ai donc été conduit à
déclarer recevable tous les amendements
qui portaient sur le contenu même de ces
négociations et à ce titre 27
amendements constitués des cavaliers
législatifs mais là encore comme
d'habitude j'ai fait prévaloir le doute
quand cela se posait j'ai ainsi sauvé
les amendements CE6 de Julien dive ce 23
de Dominique Pottier ce40 de Mathilde
dinier ce 52 de Grégoire de Fournas ce56
de Nicolas maisonnet portant notamment
sur les clauses de renégociation prévues
par egalim 2 dont l'application
défaillante conduit à soumettre au
Parlement ce projet de loi si ces
clauses de renégociation fonctionnaient
on n'aurait pas besoin de changer la
date et j'imagine que si on est obligé
de changer la date c'est que c'est close
sont probablement perfectibles ou
qu'elles mérite une certaine discussion
donc j'ai considéré qu'il y avait quand
même un lien indirect avec le projet de
loi et c'est pour ça que dans le doute
j'ai rendu recevable ces amendements
pour que nous ayons la discussion à
l'occasion de cette pardon
mais je doute tout le temps monsieur
jumelles c'est humain et donc il nous
restera madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues 47
amendements à examiner après ce filtre
que nous avons effectué j'en dis pas
plus madame la ministre encore merci de
votre présence et je vous souhaite tout
de suite la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
kasbien Monsieur le Rapporteur très cher
Alexis art mesdames messieurs
les députés être devant vous aujourd'hui
n'est pas anodin n'est jamais anodin
dont je suis moi-même convaincu que la
raison d'être du politique n'est pas
d'intervenir constamment dans les
relations commerciales entre les acteurs
privés ni de légiférer au gré de
l'actualité mais bien au contraire de
définir le cadre stable dans lequel
doivent s'établir durablement les
relations économiques mais voici que
l'inflation que nous connaissons depuis
désormais deux ans et contre laquelle le
gouvernement agit puis ses premières
manifestations viennent bousculer un
certain nombre de certitudes en matière
de politique économique c'est une
situation d'urgence qui appelle des
réponses d'urgence l'État a fixé depuis
la loi de modernisation de l'économie
LME puis avec Gallim 1 et 2 que vous
connaissez bien mesdames messieurs les
députés il a récente loi du député
d'escrosailles l'un des cadres de
négociation commerciale les plus
réglementées au monde
le président de la commission des
affaires économiques vient de le
rappeler il y a sûrement de bonnes
raisons à cela au premier rang desquels
la protection nos producteurs agricoles
dans la chaîne de valeur agroalimentaire
qu'il ne saurait pas une seule seconde
être question d'amandeir
il n'est pas non plus inutile de
rappeler que si en 2022 la France a
connu l'inflation la plus faible de la
zone euro elle le doit beaucoup à la
force de la réponse du gouvernement
structuré autour des boucliers
tarifaires mais aussi un peu à la
négociation annuelle des tarifs entre
industriels et distributeurs qui a lissé
la répercussion de la hausse des coûts
des industriels dans les prix de vente
on consommateur
mais les mêmes causes produisant les
mêmes effets c'est cette même annualité
qui aujourd'hui clairement empêche
l'inflation alimentaire de redescendre
plus rapidement et ainsi de desserrer
les taux sur les achats du quotidien des
Français dans cette lutte contre
l'inflation je crois que le pragmatisme
doit commander et chaque jour doit
compter c'est pourquoi je me présente
aujourd'hui devant vous au nom du
gouvernement avec un projet de loi qu'on
pourrait presque qualifier d'urgence et
qui porte une proposition d'adaptation
temporaire de la négociation commerciale
annuelle dont l'arsenal que nous
déployons pour lutter contre la vie
chère voici donc une nouvelle arme qui
doit accélérer encore la baisse des prix
de des produits de grande consommation
en rayon vous avez bien entendu je vous
parle bien d'accélérer des baisses
qui depuis déjà quelques semaines ont
commencé de se faire sentir en rayon sur
des produits comme les surgelés mais
aussi les changes bébé et depuis
quelques mois enfin l'inflation ralentie
notamment l'inflation alimentaire qui
comme vous le savez vient de passer sous
la barre des 10%, je rappelle qu'elle
était de 15,9% en mars dernier
et son courageant sûrement est
satisfaisant pas encore ce que
ressentent les Français c'est que
quelques produits baissent dans les
rayons mais que le caddie quand on
arrive à la caisse il ne baisse pas
assez c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons
mesdames messieurs les députés de nous
donner des moyens légaux pour que ces
baisses de prix arrivent le plus vite
possible dans le maximum de rayons
voici donc devant vous pour présenter un
projet de loi dans l'objectif est simple
clair
fondé sur du bon sens et des constats
chiffrés nous proposons d'avancer de six
semaines les négociations commerciales
entre distributeurs et industriels qui
se termineront alors le 15 janvier 2024
et non au 1er mars 2024 pour les plus
grands fournisseurs de la grande
distribution ceux qui produisent la
majorité des produits de consommation du
quotidien des Français 6 semaines de
gagner quand on est face à de
l'inflation alimentaire ça compte
mais me direz-vous sans doute comment
être sûr que les prix vont baisser et
moi aussi je souhaite aborder ce point
dès l'introduction même si je ne doute
pas que nous aurons des échanges à cet
endroit le projet de loi part d'un
raisonnement assez simple si les coûts
de plusieurs intrins agricoles baissent
sur un an il est naturel que le tarif
des produits fabriqués à partir de ces
intrants baisse et que cette baisse se
retrouve sur le ticket de caisse des
Français
or les cours d'importantes matières
premières agricoles ont baissé depuis un
an
du blé tendre ont chuté de 40%. depuis
l'automne 22 le prix des oléagineux
pardonnez-moi recul fortement aussi est
inférieur de 17% à son niveau 12 21 sans
vous noyer de chiffres l'Insee a
également indiqué qu'en août 2023 vous
le savez les prix agricoles à la
production continue de reculer pour
s'établir à -7,4% en glissement annuel
il y a aussi des baisses d'autres
matières premières industrielles je
pense au papier je pense au carton pour
les emballages par exemple ou encore les
prix de l'énergie qui reviennent à la
baisse après un emballement irrationnel
pour nos entreprises l'an passé je
pourrais multiplier les exemples bien
sûr il y a aussi certaines matières
premières qui subissent encore des
hausses de prix
mais c'est l'arbre qui une fois n'est
pas coutume ne serait cachée la forêt
des baisses attendues telle est mesdames
messieurs les députés le texte tout
simple que le gouvernement vous propose
je n'ignore pas bien sûr que des
questions se posent notre objectif
partagé de souveraineté alimentaire et
industrielles qui passent par la
préservation des conditions négociations
de nos PME agroalimentaires est une
priorité et le gouvernement souhaite
travailler avec vous en ce sens c'est
une demande forte de leur part et je
crois qu'elle est partagée par tous y
compris par les distributeurs et par la
ministre que je suis vous l'aurez
compris mesdames messieurs les députés
le texte n'a jamais été depuis le
contexte n'a jamais été depuis deux ans
aussi favorable à des baisses de prix de
produits alimentaires en rayon on n'a
pas de temps à perdre nous devons sans
plus attendre permettre aux industriels
et aux distributeurs de semelles dès à
présent à la table des négociations
certains industriels ont déjà envoyé
leur CGV conditions générales de vente
au distributeur je les appelle
solennellement à amplifier ce mouvement
sans plus attendre un dernier mot ce qui
compte
au choix je sais qu'on va mettre tous
les mêmes références mais les deux sont
valables c'est pas la ligne de départ
c'est la ligne d'arrivée et pour le coup
pour paraphraser une phrase que vous
connaissez aussi bien que moi pour le
coup c'est autant la chute que
l'atterrissage les industriels comme
chaque année vont proposer des tarifs à
la hausse
les industriels je le redis vont
proposer
c'était pas l'objectif monsieur le
député jumelle je le redis parce que je
suis pas sûr que vous voulez bien
entendu les industriels vont comme
chaque année proposer des tarifs à la
hausse oui
les distributeurs sont pleins de ronds
oui
mais oui ces nouveaux tarifs seront
apremment négociés vous connaissez ces
négociations commerciales des nuits
entières et c'est bien pour ça que
chaque jour compte ce qui compte c'est
qu'à l'issue des négociations les prix
baissent même si à l'entrée ils étaient
en hausse mesdames messieurs je crois
que nous visons un même résultat ne pas
perdre de temps pour redonner le plus
vite possible du pouvoir d'achat aux
Français et pour terminer je crois qu'il
n'est pas lieu aujourd'hui de se
retrancher derrière des postulats
économiques ou autres théories il s'agit
simplement de répondre à une question
acceptez-vous oui ou non d'avancer de
six semaines les renégociations
commerciales pour que nous gagnions six
semaines sur la baisse des prix je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
Alexis c'est vous merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues alors pour commencer je suis
heureux d'être rapporteur pour la
première fois du projet de loi dont nous
allons débattre aujourd'hui
il s'agit d'un texte volontairement bref
et opérationnel qui comporte une mesure
unique l'avancement de la date butoir
des négociations commerciales entre
distributeurs et fournisseurs pour 2024
l'objectif que se fixe le gouvernement
et la majorité est simple faire gagner 6
semaines de pouvoir d'achat au français
en accent en accélérant la baisse des
prix au consommateurs qui devrait
résulter de la baisse des prix des
matières premières et de l'énergie
nécessaire à la fabrication des produits
de grande distribution
la lutte contre l'inflation qui rend
difficile la vie quotidienne de nombreux
français et l'un des combats principaux
que nous menons avec le gouvernement je
pense à des mesures très concrètes comme
le bouclier tarifaire l'aide
d'exceptionnel de rentrer la
revalorisation des bourses étudiantes
des aides APL des minima sociaux des
retraites ou encore l'indemnité
carburant destiné aux travailleurs
je pense également à des dispositifs qui
concernent plus précisément les produits
de grande consommation monsieur jumelles
comme le trimestre anti-inflation et les
renégociations commerciales visant à
faire baisser les prix de 5000 produits
du quotidien
il me semble que tous les leviers
doivent être employés pour faire baisser
les prix au plus vite et que ce projet
de loi constitue l'un de ses leviers
nous partons du constat que les prix
Hamon sont en baisse c'est le cas
notamment et la ministre ou l'a rappelé
des matières premières agricoles dont
les céréales les vins les fruits et les
légumes même s'il y a une grande
disparité les oléagineux le café la
volaille et les œufs il en va de même
pour de nombreuses matières premières
non agricoles comme le papier le
caoutchouc ou encore le bois
on assiste dans le même temps à une
normalisation du prix de l'énergie et un
début de baisse du baril du Brent
or je le rappelle en mars 2022 juste
après la clôture des négociations
commerciales le gouvernement avait
demandé à la grande distribution de
rouvrir les négociations afin de
concéder des hausses à leur fournisseurs
elles étaient évidemment à l'époque
absolument nécessaires et sans cela il
est très probable que notre industrie
agroalimentaire aurait été laminé
nous assistons cependant aujourd'hui au
mouvement inverse à celui de mars 2022
c'est-à-dire un reflux des coûts des
fournisseurs nous pouvons donc anticiper
sur un certain nombre de produits une
baisse des prix qui doit être répercutée
au plus vite dans les rayons pour les
consommateurs
c'est pour cette raison que le projet de
loi propose pour l'année 2024 d'avancer
de six semaines la date butoir des
négociations commerciales afin que le 16
janvier au plus tard les Français
puissent profiter d'une baisse de prix
sur un certain nombre de produits du
quotidien
s'il n'y a pas de doute sur la
philosophie de ce texte qui au fond
constitue un simple accélérateur
l'efficacité du dispositif mais aussi
son équité vis-à-vis des différents
acteurs dépendent d'un certain nombre
d'ajustements
les auditions que j'ai menées m'ont
conduit à m'interroger sur certains
points et j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
remercier l'ensemble des personnes qui
sont rendues disponibles pour répondre à
mes questions dans des délais
extrêmement contraints puisque j'ai
rencontré en trois jours plus de 25
organisations syndicats agricoles
distributeurs fournisseurs
administration nationale et européenne
cabinets ministériel économiste ou
encore journalistes spécialisés
je note d'ailleurs que vos amendements
reflètent les interrogations qui sont
les miennes et que je vais essayer de
résumer très rapidement
d'abord il y a la question du seuil
le texte pour le moment fixe un seuil à
150 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires ce qui représente environ 300
entreprises non seulement de très
grandes multinationales mais aussi des
ETI
certains proposent de fixer le seuil à
350 millions d'euros ce qui permettrait
de limiter le dispositif aux 75 plus
grandes entreprises qui semblaient
prioritairement être visés par le
gouvernement une autre solution
consisterait à supprimer tout simplement
ce seuil ce qui avancerait les
négociations pour tous les fournisseurs
indépendamment de leur taille
cette solution qui évite de distinguer
les gros et les petits mamène
naturellement à mon second point celui
des conséquences du texte pour nos TPE
et PME
j'ai reçu le président de la fève lors
de mes auditions et j'entends
l'inquiétude des entreprises qu'il
représente traditionnellement l'usage
veut que les PME soit négociés avant les
grands groupes généralement avant le 1er
janvier ce qui est le fruit d'un patient
de travail de la fève qui a conclu avec
la grande distribution des accords sur
ce point ça leur permet de négocier dans
de meilleures conditions et de
bénéficier de meilleures contreparties
les PME craignent donc de se retrouver
dans des conditions dégradées si elles
négocie après le 15 janvier et de ne pas
pouvoir négocier avant même si elle le
voulait du fait de l'engorgement
provoquera la négociation des grands
groupes sur une période réduite
d'un autre côté forcer la loi forcée par
la loi l'ensemble des PME à passer avant
le 31 décembre comme le demande la FEF
et beaucoup de vos amendements me paraît
délicat car cela créerait pour les
entreprises qui ne seraient pas prêtes à
agir dans des délais aussi serrés un
risque juridique fort
alors je le répète aujourd'hui les PME
négocient avant les grands groupes mais
elles ne sont pas tenues de le faire
elles ne risquent rien si elles ne le
font pas et d'ailleurs elles ne le font
pas toutes
la solution proposée par le gouvernement
qui tient dans la signature d'une charte
entre PME et distributeur me paraît
offrir un bon équilibre entre sécurité
et contraintes je laisserai peut-être
d'ailleurs madame la ministre développée
ce point et nous indiquer si ce projet
de charte et désormais opérationnel
aussi la suppression du seuil des 150
millions évoqué plutôt me paraît une
solution adaptée pour résoudre la double
problématique celle du champ des acteurs
concernés afin d'inclure l'ensemble des
fournisseurs sans distinction et celle
de la date afin de permettre à
l'ensemble des PME qui n'auront pas
signé au 31-12 de négocier au même
niveau que les grands groupes
ce pesant en enlevant cette limite nous
permettront que malgré un contexte
exceptionnel les négociations se
déroulent le plus sereinement et qui
tablement est presque le plus
normalement possible
ensuite il y a un enjeu purement
opérationnel qui est celui de la durée
des négociations j'ai été assez
convaincu par les arguments de ceux qui
disent qu'il n'est pas possible de
passer de 90 jours à 45 jours de
négociation sans conséquence sur la
qualité de celle-ci j'aimerais donc que
nous puissions porter à 60 jours cette
durée des négociations en avançant la
date d'envoi des conditions générales de
vente aux 15 novembre
voilà les interrogations soulève pour
moi le dispositif tel qu'il nous est
présenté mais il y a aussi bien sûr tout
ce qui n'est pas dans le texte mais sur
lequel la question de la date butoir
nous invite à nous interroger en
conclusion de ce propos liminaire je
voudrais élargir un peu le débat pour
aborder deux sujets qui me paraissent
essentiels
la date butoir des négociations existent
depuis 2008 elle est désormais la clé de
voûte de l'architecture des relations
commerciales une architecture complexe
sur laquelle le législature n'a cessé de
travailler depuis la loi de
modernisation de l'économie nous sommes
revenus à plusieurs reprises depuis 2017
avec la loi egalim 1 et Gallim 2 et plus
récemment avec la loi portée en 2023 par
notre collègue Frédéric descrosale notre
objectif est constant rééquilibrer les
relations commerciales entre les
maillons les plus faibles de la chaîne
et en particulier nos agriculteurs et
les maillons les plus forts
aujourd'hui la date butoir du 1er mars
constitue une protection pour certains
mais exacerbe également les tensions et
les crispations
on peut même penser que certains
dispositifs votés dans le cadre des lois
que je viens de citer comme les clauses
de renégociation et de révision
automatique des prix créer ou élargi par
égalim 2 serait mieux rédigé par les
acteurs et peut-être plus opérationnel
si on supprimait cette date butoir
par ailleurs les successions de crises
économiques sanitaires et
environnementales ont prouvé que
l'encadrement juridique français des
négociations étaient insuffisamment
adaptables les interventions multiples
du gouvernement et du législateur sur
cette question en témoigne il me semble
donc essentiel sous une forme ou une
autre de repenser ce cadre afin d'en
accroître la résilience et
l'adaptabilité tout en préservant et en
renforçant les acquis des lois dit
egalim 1 et Gallim 2 et descrosailles
l'autre enjeu qui est revenu très
fréquemment dans le cadre des auditions
mais aussi de nos débats législatifs
c'est la question des centrales d'achat
international
que certains d'entre vous ici
connaissent particulièrement bien dès
2019 cette question avait été au cœur
des travaux de la commission d'enquête
de Monsieur Thierry Benoît
la loi portée par Monsieur Frédéric
descrosailles en mars dernier a permis
des avancées majeures le phénomène t’en
néanmoins à s'amplifier et sans doute
faudrait-il agir au niveau européen pour
l'encadrer davantage c'est en tout cas
un enjeu majeur pour garantir
l'effectivité de ce que nous votons pour
finir nous entamons l'étude d'un texte
court qui vise à répondre à une
situation d'urgence bien qu'il soulève
également des débats à plus long terme
je souhaite donc vivement que notre
Commission puisse procéder à des débats
sereins et constructives comme elle sait
le faire afin d'apporter ensemble une
réponse aux hausse des prix dans les
rayons je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur je
vous propose de passer aux orateurs de
groupe comme d'habitude on va prendre
chacun des orateurs de groupe 4 minutes
globales maximum 3 minutes si vous
souhaitez prendre une intervention de 3
minutes et on laisse une minute pour que
madame le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur au choix puisse
éventuellement compléter si besoin était
on commence tout de suite avec Pierre
Cazeneuve pour le groupe Renaissance
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur le texte
proposé par le gouvernement repose sur
un principe particulièrement simple
après un choc d'inflation exceptionnel
en 2022 le prix de nombreuses matières
premières du coût de l'énergie est en
train de baisser en 2023 ce qui devrait
entraîner mécaniquement une baisse des
produits agroalimentaires l'idée donc
d'avancer le plus possible la date
butoir des négociations commerciales
afin de répercuter ses baisses de prix
le plus rapidement possible sur le
pouvoir d'achat des Français le groupe
Renaissance et bien sûr favorable à
cette initiative mais aborde cette
solutions avec humilité humilité tout
d'abord car nous parlons d'un sujet
extraordinairement sensible celui du
pouvoir d'achat du quotidien des
Français de ce qu'ils mettent dans le
dans leur caddie ou plus précisément de
ce qu'il ne mette plus dans leur caddie
car je rappelle que selon le métier plus
de 1 Français sur deux à modifier et
changer ses habitudes de consommation
alimentaire depuis le début de la crise
humilité ensuite car on sait qu'il
n'existe pas de solution miracle et que
ce texte ne doit pas être interprété ni
présenter tel quel contrairement aux
révolutionnaires de gala qui nous feront
croire qu'ils sont capables de répondre
à l'ensemble des préoccupations des
Français en bloquant les prix ou en
supprimant la TVA nous croyons ici aux
mesures aux mesures aux mesures
pragmatiques
aux mesures pragmatiques et concrètes
comme nous l'avons fait avec le
l'explorateur group terminé j'ai case 9
poursuivez ne faites pas attention comme
nous l'avons fait avec le blocage
tarif le bouclier tarifaire pardon sur
NRJ ainsi que sur les mesures ciblées
elles ont été énoncées par le rapporteur
sur la revalorisation des bourses des
aPL la revalorisation des minimas
sociaux humidité enfin quand même car
derrière nos danettes les paquets de
pâtes les boîtes de cassoulet il y a
évidemment les agriculteurs et celles et
ceux qui nous nourrissent et que nous
devons continuer à protéger la dynamique
amorcée par égalim 1 parigalim 2 par la
PPL d'escrosa il doit absolument être
préservé c'est d'ailleurs tout le sens
de ce qu'a souhaité mettre en place le
président lors de sa dernière
intervention sur la conférence pour
modérer les marges nous y serons donc
particulièrement vigilant tout au long
de l'examen de ce texte je vous remercie
merci y a-t-il une réaction non
obligatoire mais si vous souhaitez
réagir monsieur rapporteur ou madame la
ministre sinon on passe à l'orateur
suivant
c'est bien on passe à l'orateur suivant
du coup Monsieur Nicolas maisonnet pour
le groupe instrument national oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
se rapporteur alors que depuis plus de
deux ans donc les Français subissent une
inflation galopante explosion du prix
des énergies du prix des carburants
inflation alimentaire de plus de 20 %
nous allons donc débattre aujourd'hui
d'un projet de loi intitulé mesure
d'urgence relative ou négociations
commerciales dans la grande distribution
mesure avec un S ce qui est assez
cocasse puisqu'il n'en reste plus qu'une
seule suite au camouflé qu'à essuyé le
gouvernement face à la mesure absurde de
la vente à perte des carburants donc une
mesure est restante qui vise à avancer
la date de six semaines des négociations
commerciales entre les industriels et la
grande distribution et c'est donc cela
tout ce qui vous reste j'ai envie de
dire dans votre dans votre besace pour
redonner un peu d'oxygène au
portefeuille des Français un maigre
projet de loi qualifié d'ailleurs de
coups de coup de com de Bruno Le Maire
par votre cabinet me semble madame la
ministre dont personne aujourd'hui
personne aujourd'hui n'est en mesure
d'affirmer avec certitude si oui ou non
il aura réellement un effet
déflationniste d'ailleurs monsieur le
Président vous avez dit que certains
acteurs
économiques étaient enthousiastes à ce
projet ce n'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
ressenti lors des auditions aucun
enthousiasme en tout cas pas dans
l'enthousiasme débordant ni côté
distributeur ni côté des fournisseurs et
on se demande aujourd'hui même si les
PME les ETI ne vont pas en subir un
préjudice et vous avez dit Madame la
Ministre un texte tout simple ça pour
être simple c'est simple c'est même
c'est même simpliste et clairement
insuffisant compte tenu de ce que sont
en droit d'attendre nos compatriotes et
pour cause vous ne vous attaquez jamais
à la racine aux racines de l'inflation
alors certes vous allez me dire qu'il y
a un contexte le covid la guerre en
Ukraine mais aussi mais aussi des
comportements d'acteurs économiques
aussi bien du point de vue des
fournisseurs que des distributeurs avec
des marges exorbitantes et aussi des
décisions politiques ce qui est le cas
avec votre politique énergétique la non
contestation des règles du marché
européen des énergies par exemple donc
puisque vous êtes à court de solution je
vais essayer rapidement de vous en
proposer quelques-unes donc la baisse de
la TVA que nous prenons sur l'ensemble
des énergies devint à 5,5 la suppression
de la TVA sur un panier de 100 produits
de première nécessité nous disons aussi
que dans ce contexte de crise Léda
l'État doit intervenir dans
l'encadrement des prix alors c'est pas
l'encadrement des prix c'est pas le
clair ou Carrefour au pays des soviettes
mais nous considérons que dans cette
partie de poker menteur à laquelle on
l'a assisté entre fournisseurs et
distributeurs l'État doit être capable
de reprendre en main d'encadrer les prix
avec un plan C qui protège nos
agriculteurs nos producteurs mais aussi
un plafond qui qui permettrait d'éviter
les marges les marges trop importantes
voilà donc des solutions que nous
pensons utiles et effic aces pour nos
compatriotes
merci beaucoup monsieur maisonnet j'en
profite puisque vous m'avez vous m'avez
dit vous avez entendu les acteurs être
sur le sujet mais moi en audition j'ai
entendu monsieur chaleur de Système U
dire je cite ce BGL en le soutient je
n'ose imaginais qu'il n'avait pas au
bout il y a aussi monsieur biero de Lidl
qui a soutenu et il y a un communiqué de
la FCD qui dit les anciennes de la
grande distribution appelle donc sur la
mêmement le Parlement à voter en faveur
donc moi je vote collaborateur était
présent à certaines des auditions mais
moi j'ai entendu ça en audition mais
après peut-être monsieur le rapporteur
pour compléter
y a-t-il une réaction madame le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
éventuellement j'entends la même chose
monsieur le rapporteur non moi j'ai bien
entendu que les acteurs étaient prêts à
tout faire pour faire baisser les prix
avec la même ambition que la nôtre
simplement sur sur votre intervention
j'entends d'abord une attaque sur la
forme vous critiquer le titre dont acte
nous ce qu'on veut c'est agir pour les
Français ensuite vous nous parlez sans
grande surprise de votre proposition
phare la seule unique qu'on entend à
chaque fois celle de la TVA pour autant
on l'a essayé une fois en France et j'ai
l'impression qu'on vous répète à chaque
fois les mêmes arguments parce que vous
nous répétez à chaque fois la même
proposition mais sur la TVA on va vous
rappeler l'exemple de la restauration ou
une baisse de la TVA ne se traduit pas
par une baisse des prix et on pourrait
aussi vous rappeler les pays qui
essaient cette mesure et qui finalement
ne fonctionne pas parce que ce n'est pas
parce que vous baissez la TVA et que
vous baissez donc les recettes de l'État
et j'entends par les recettes de l'État
l'ensemble de l'argent qui va aller dans
nos dans nos écoles et dans un hôpitaux
mais vous ne baisserez pas les prix
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Madame Mathilde lignée pour le groupe
la France insoumise c'est à vous merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
notre pays donc fait face aujourd'hui à
une situation de grave urgence
alimentaire les 37 produits du quotidien
du panier de course coûte 20 euros de
plus au mois d'août 2023 qu'un an
auparavant un français sur 6 ne mange
pas à sa fin les restos du cœur
s'attendent à servir 170 millions de
repas cette année les prix augmentent
mais les salaires ne suivent pas pour
2023 les hausses de salaire sont
attendues à 4,5% en moyenne pour une
inflation à 5% et malgré cet état des
lieux alarmants vous proposez simplement
d'avancer les négociations commerciales
non mais sérieusement ce projet est une
blague nous allons de déception
déception l'objectif était pourtant
clair faire face à l'augmentation des
prix alimentaires on est dans le nouvel
épisode de Bruno demande il demande aux
multinationales de la gros business de
bien vouloir renégocier avec la grande
distribution pour faire baisser les prix
c'est même multinationales qui se sont
gavées toute l'année sur le dos de
l'inflation le taux le démarche des
industries agroalimentaires à augmenter
de 71% en un an et demi s'il n'avait pas
augmenté leur marge les prix de
production agroalimentaire aurait
augmenté deux fois moins vite
depuis le début 2022 vous croyez
vraiment que ceux qui nourrissent
l'inflation alimentaire depuis des mois
vont s'arrêter maintenant la grande
distribution a aussi fait du profit sur
le dos de l'inflation alors certes moins
mais elle a surtout augmenté ses marges
sur les produits pour lesquels les
industriels n'avaient pas n'avaient pas
ou peu augmenté les leurs donc tout le
monde y gagne sauf les consommateurs et
ce projet de loi n'aura que pour
conséquence d'avancer les négociations
de 45 jours nous sommes sceptiques très
sceptiques même quant à la réelle
utilité de cette mesure rien ne nous
garantit que l'avancée des négociations
commerciales ne conduisent pas au
contraire à une augmentation des prix
pour l'Insee il n'y a pas de il n'y aura
pas de baisse de prix mais seulement un
ralentissement à la hausse ajoutons à
cela les déclarations faites par les
acteurs de la grande distribution la
semaine la dernière dans notre
commission pour pour le président du
Groupement les Mousquetaires les tarifs
annoncés pour pour entamer ces
négociations seront sur la base d'une
hausse de 5 à 15% sur les produits donc
tout porte à croire que ce texte n'aura
aucun effet ou au contraire fera
augmenter les prix alimentaires donc
déjà des vrais solutions pour lutter
contre l'inflation il y a indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation bloqué à la
baisse les marches des industriels
agroalimentaires et et de la grande
distribution et l'extension du bouclier
qui a des qualités prix à l'ensemble du
territoire national alors moi je crois
que pour améliorer la vie de nos
concitoyens il y a urgence à sortir des
mesurettes parce qu'il faut vraiment
lutter la contre l'inflation je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président moi
c'est Olivia donc Bruno demande mais
c'est Olivia qui est là aujourd'hui donc
je vous laisse toute liberté je connais
votre talent pour l'adapter
mais bon c'est un écrivain qui a écrit
ça il y a pas longtemps non je voulais
juste redire madame la députée redonner
quelques chiffres on sera certainement
pas d'accord mais d'abord je rappelle
quand même qu'une négociation dans
l'agroalimentaire démarre rarement à la
baisse
que ça démarre fréquemment à la hausse
et que c'est le cœur de la négociation
démarre à la hausse pour ensuite aller
chercher des baisses je veux juste vous
rappeler de façon très factuelle
juillet 22 juillet 23 le blé tendre -30%
le maïs - 25 les huiles de colza soja
tournesol les moins 27,6 donc je dis
juste simplement une façon neutre que
nous sommes en droit d'attendre contenu
de l'importance de ces matières
premières agricoles dans la constitution
des produits que ce soit des produits de
MDD ou d'industriels une baisse des prix
je n'ai pas nié j'ai même précisé dans
l'introduction qu'il n'avait pas échappé
que certaines que certains cours
continuent à augmenter mais
majoritairement les MPa constituent le
cœur de l'agroalimentaire sont en baisse
je mets juste à vous le rappeler merci
beaucoup madame la ministre je vous
propose de passer à Monsieur Jérôme Dury
pour le couple les républicains oui
merci monsieur le Président Madame
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
collègue faire ses courses devient un
casse-tête pour une grande partie de nos
concitoyens si ce n'est pas une source
d'angoisse car ce combat contre la
hausse des prix qui nous réunit autour
de ce texte et bien concret pour celles
et ceux qui sont à l'Europe
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
saluons cette volonté de travailler
ensemble à une solution qui je l'espère
ira au-delà des clivages partisans
stériles sur le sujet travailler
ensemble c'est avant tout se dire les
choses le texte qui nous est présenté
n'est pas celui qui a été attendu
initialement exit la possibilité de
vendre à perte carburant pour t'annoncer
en grande pompe par le gouvernement elle
a tout simplement disparu du texte le
carburant évidemment trop cher ne doit
pas être un au cœur d'un coup de
communication il serait préférable de
rapidement prendre des mesures pour
faire baisser le prix à la pompe qui a
fixer aujourd'hui sur tous les ruraux
qui se servent dans leur quotidien de la
voiture
quant à l'article restant force de
constater qu'il ne fait pas l'unanimité
l'industrie française reste fragile la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie les
investissements massifs en matière de
transition environnementale ou encore
l'appel à la hausse des salaires sont
autant de coûts supplémentaires qu'il
faut un moment répercuter sur le coût du
produit et donc rien ne nous permet
d'affirmer que faire passer les plus
gros industriels avant nos PME dans ses
négociations commerciales engendrera une
baisse massive des prix pourtant nous
pouvons être en mesure de penser que ces
industriels pourraient en dégager des
avantages considérables en matière de
référencement de placement à rayon ou de
promotion et nous ne sommes pas certains
que nos PME qui font également vivre nos
territoires ruraux puissant sortir nous
serons pour cela force de proposition
d'abord sur la renforcement des
sanctions contre une partie de la grande
distribution qui préfère passer par
Madrid ou Bruxelles plutôt que de
respecter la loi française
deuxièmement sur le calendrier même des
négociations où l'on crée une distorsion
de concurrence ou sur le seuil des 150
millions qui pourrait être alignés sur
la norme européenne des 350 millions
avec également deux points de vigilance
l'exclusion de la filière lait du
dispositif dont il faut la regarder dans
son ensemble et où la différence de
calendrier ne serait pas comprise par la
filière et sur la notion de date butoir
dont nous pouvons discuter
d'amélioration possible mais que nous
devons conserver dans ce projet de loi
c'est une notion majeure pour respecter
notre agriculture et notre souveraineté
alimentaire vous l'aurez compris notre
groupe se place dans une démarche
constructive à l'approche de ce texte
pour trouver des solutions quand on
inflation mais sans fragiliser notre
tissu industriel
merci beaucoup monsieur nuri-y est-il
une réaction notre apporteur de Madame
la Ministre non et bien je vous propose
de passer donc à Madame Anne-Laure
Babeau pour le groupe démocrate c'est à
vous merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur le
groupe démocrate prend note par ce texte
que le gouvernement pour objectif de
réduire l'inflation nous soutenant cette
initiative du gouvernement espérons que
la négociation entre les distributeurs
et les industriels le permettra
le gouvernement propose d'avancer donc
des négociations commerciales au 15
janvier entre les distributeurs et les
multinationales tout en laissant les PME
et négocier jusqu'au 1er mars pour bien
connaître ce sujet il y en négocié dans
les boxes de distributeur comme vous le
disiez madame la ministre des nuits
entières et j'ajouterai dans des
conditions difficiles pour les
fournisseurs je tiens alerter le
gouvernement sur le fait que cette
proposition de texte pourrait desservir
nos PME ETI dans sa rédaction actuelle
dans ces négociations l'objectif est de
négocier un prix face à des
contreparties or par ce texte quand les
multinationales auront négocié au 15
janvier leur contrepartie les PME ETI ne
pourront négocier de manière équilibrée
en passant les grandes entreprises cette
année le contexte des taux d'intérêt
élevé va inviter les distributeurs à
limiter leur stock encore plus qu'à leur
habitude donc à choisir des produits à
forte rotation de fait à réduire l'offre
à le concentrer sur les meilleures
ventes des multinationales on reste
régnant drastiquement l'offre des
petites marques or les consommateurs
apprécient aussi de trouver de la
diversité dans le rayon au travers des
produits de PME française et des
produits locaux
tout en protégeant les consommateurs
face à l'inflation le modèle économique
dans lequel nous sommes encore favorise
le distributeurs et les multinationales
la politique du prix bas portée avec
force par certains distributeurs
desserts nos agriculteurs nos PME au TI
et sert aux Français des produits
alimentaires de basse qualité les
multinationales comme les distributeurs
doivent davantage participer aux
partages de la valeur il en va de notre
souveraineté alimentaire le groupe
démocrate défend avec constance cette
conviction l'exigence d'une alimentation
de qualité d'une meilleure protection de
nos agriculteurs et de nos PME ETI pour
toutes ces raisons nous avons déposé
plusieurs amendements basés sur la
différenciation entre les
multinationales et les PME ETI ce projet
de loi est l'occasion d'inscrire à titre
temporaire cette différenciation dans le
Code de commerce le groupe démocrate
propose donc que la date butoir des PME
ETI soit 15 jours avant celles des
multinationales
j'ajouterai par rapport à vos prises de
parole si certaines chartes soumettent
la possibilité d'un accord au 31
décembre entre PME distributeur ce n'est
que 20% des PME qui s'accordent avant
cette date 80% donc ne s'accordent pas
avant et donc vont jusqu'au 1er mars par
ailleurs concernant la suppression de la
date butoir au 1er mars il semble utile
de l'étudier en prenant le temps via
peut-être une mission parlementaire tant
l'impact de cette décision pourrait être
fatale pour certaines entreprises mais
pourraient peut-être aussi apaiser les
relations entre fournisseurs et
distributeurs si le dispositif est bien
encadré je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame babot y a-t-il une
réaction de notre rapporteur Madame le
Ministre non c'est très clair nous
passons donc à Monsieur Dominique petit
pour le groupe socialiste merci monsieur
le Président c'est une petite mesure au
singulier on pourrait me dire une mesure
est ceci dit le groupe socialiste
l'aborde avec je sais pas comment vous
qualifierez le majorité des a traité de
grande opérateurs de galaches pas très
bien compris je vais vous faire un aveu
on regarde cette proposition de façon
attentive dans des concentré c'est
d'être utile et s'il y a des garanties
suffisantes on la votera sinon
évidemment on se méfiera mais c'est pas
la peine d'hystériser le débat on est on
est sur on est sur une mesure très
conjoncturelle qui est pas du tout à la
hauteur des enjeux et on peut se le dire
avec un peu d'humidité la question
sociale qui est posée par l'inflation et
tragique et aujourd'hui 9 10 millions de
français pour qui la fin du mois devient
une question existentielle état de de
catégorie je vais pas faire ici dans le
bateau mais de théorie de Français qui
sont dans une très grande souffrance et
je crois que si on prend l'ensemble des
mesures gouvernementales qui sont
engagées on peut déjà se dire avec
sincérité qu'elles ne sont pas à la
hauteur regardons néanmoins celle-ci
nous aurions aimé pour notre part
malheureusement le cadre limité de la
loi ne le permet pas qu'on aurait pu
revenir sur un effort équivalent entre
la grande distribution et l'industrie
agroalimentaire prenez plus engager
véritablement les conditions d'un
soutien par les consommateurs des
contrats tripartite plus annuel
garantissant une répartition équitable
du bénéfice entre toutes les parties
reconnaissant le travail de chacun on
aurait aimé que la question des
Outre-mer soit prise en compte parce que
si la situation est tragique en France
elle est extrêmement tragique dans les
outre-mer nous aimerions un minima et
c'est le centre des amendements qui ont
survécu à la sélection naturelle qui a
été faite par rapport l'administration
de l'assemblée que la question du
respect non seulement décalé mais de
sapin 2 égalim et d'escrosailles soient
garantie nous aimerions qu'il y ait pas
de remise en cause de la nualité des
négociations
et que nous ayons des garanties que les
mécanismes de révision des prix qui
génèrent cette loi soit effectif afin
que nous n'ayons pas tous les six mois à
revenir sur ces questions là la question
de la révision des prix de ces
mécanismes et la véritable défaillance
qui révélée par cette loi enfin je me
permets j'attends pas vraiment je serai
heureux d'avoir une réponse mais je
croyais que vous affirmer ça au nom du
groupe social c'est vrai sujet on les a
pas abordés les vrais sujets ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui au niveau de la grande
distribution depuis la LME une situation
d'oligarchie qui a été maintes fois
défendu et qu'on a certaines
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire qui
sont en situation de monopole parce
qu'elles ont la puissance sur notre
imaginaire et qui a une sorte de roman
national des marques qui leur permet
d'imposer n'importe quelle condition
commerciale au distributeur c'est de
cette double servitude dont nous devons
sortir l'enjeu est celui d'une
démocratie économique et sociale
merci beaucoup monsieur potier est-ce
que madame la ministre monsieur
rapporteur madame la ministre en une
phrase monsieur le député potier
merci de rappeler l'état d'esprit en
tout cas qui est le mien en tout cas
dans le cadre du gouvernement je vous
l'ai dit en introduction j'entends la
déception mais je vous fais pas si avec
des guillemets passer des vessies pour
des long terme cette loi elle a un
objectif gagner 42 jours
et je ne nie pas qu'un certain nombre de
sujets que vous avez abordés se pose
merci pas d'autres remarque nous passons
donc à notre prochaine orateur de groupe
et il s'agit de Monsieur Thierry Benoit
pour le groupe horizon chers collègues
c'est à vous merci monsieur le Président
donc du groupe horizon
d'emblée je vais dire que nous allons
voter la proposition du gouvernement
je dirais bien ça mange pas de pain mais
sincèrement c'est pas ça qui va sauver
la question de
l'inflation des denrées alimentaires
pour nos concitoyens j'allais dire tout
est dans la loi d'escrosailles non mais
la loi d'escrosailles que nous venons de
voter qui est à peine appliqué
appliquons là et puis allons plus loin
je le dis tout net alors les
négociations commerciales
le texte concerne les grands du des
grands fournisseurs les grands
industriels et la grande distribution et
il y a en effet un risque Anne-Laure
baboul a évoqué tout à l'heure c'est que
par cette proposition de mettre en
isolement les grands de l'industrie et
les multinationales que ce soit eux qui
donnent le la des négociations en disant
mais ça a bien été accepté par les
multinationales par les grands
industriels il n'y a pas de raison que
les DPE ne l'acceptent pas où il faut
qu'on se gendarme et c'est malheureux
parce qu'on a tout inventé en France on
a la DGCCRF l'Autorité de la concurrence
l'observation de la formation des prix
des marges la Commission d'examen des
pratiques commerciales l'Autorité de la
concurrence au niveau européen on a tout
inventé en France et en Europe mais on a
affaire on les a eu la semaine dernière
ils sont adorables les grandes
distribution ils ont chaque matin une
tribune dans les quotidiens papiers dans
la presse donc la presse les journaux
radios à la télévision
Michel Édouard Leclerc qui est
l'ambassadeur du groupe Leclerc mais de
l'ensemble de la distribution puisque
tous les matins il parle au nom de
l'ensemble des acteurs de la
distribution et on voit bien qu'il nous
baladent il a plus de pouvoir
aujourd'hui en matière de commerce que
ne peut l'avoir un ministre de
l'agriculture ou un ministre du Commerce
ici en France et c'est
dommage je trouve qu'il faut aller
au-delà notamment au niveau européen et
il faut ce gendarmer pour que cet
écosystème qui a été créé par le secteur
de la grande distribution et notamment
les centrales internationales et bien on
y met de l'ordre on exige plus de
transparence qu'il y a des sanctions
pour ce qui concerne les mauvaises
pratiques les mauvaises pratiques et
puis à partir de des services que nous
avons les services fiscaux les urssafs
on est capable de voir précisément les
marges des grands industriels ou les
marges des distributeurs moi je suis un
fervent défenseur de la TVA social
certains proposent de un taux réduit ou
un taux zéro sur certains produits
alimentaires moi je pense que la crise
covid nous a permis d'identifier et bien
les produits indispensables pour les
consommateurs et j'aimerais bien que le
gouvernement dans les mois qui viennent
ouvre ce débat de la TVA social en
France parce que la question des dents
réalimentaires qui est en étroite
connexion avec les productions agricoles
et bien je trouve que c'est un sujet
après sur la date elle-même des
négociations le président de la
commission l'a évoqué tout à l'heure et
Madame la Ministre aussi moi je ne suis
pas fermé en effet à l'idée de dire par
exemple
si on veut avoir un prix de négociation
qui est connecté à la réalité les
céréales ça se récolte fin de printemps
début d'été et on pourrait imaginer que
une partie des négociations ait lieu
juste après et bien les récoltes pour
être en adéquation avec les productions
de nos agriculteurs donc nous voterons
ce texte même si je pense que c'est pas
ça qui va apporter la solution aux
problèmes du moment merci beaucoup si ça
vous va je vous propose de passer au
prochain orateur il s'agit de Madame la
Ministre Delphine bateau pour le groupe
écologiste c'est à vous merci monsieur
le Président Madame la monsieur le
rapporteur qui aurait pu prédire la
vague d'inflation ou la crise climatique
aux effets spectaculaires demandaient le
président de la République lors de ses
vœux le 31 décembre dernier si la
deuxième partie de la phrase a
légitimement fait réagir nombre de
scientifiques spécialistes du climat la
première à moins retenu la tension alors
qu'elle aurait dû car tout le problème
de la politique actuelle et qu'elle
repose sur une erreur de diagnostic et
sur un manque de lucidité l'inflation
n'a pas commencé avec la guerre en
Ukraine mais dès 2021 avec la boulimie
de reprise de la croissance économique
après la pandémie et sur fond de
catastrophes climatiques affectant les
denrées alimentaires mais en juin 2021
le ministre de l'Économie nous dit nous
n'avons pas de préoccupations
particulières sur la poussée de
l'inflation en novembre 2021 notre
évaluation est que l'inflation est
temporaire en février 2022 le scénario
principal du gouvernement et la baisse
de l'inflation à partir de la fin
d'année 2022 et maintenant
nous promet nous allons sortir de cette
inflation je suis sûr que l'inflation va
baisser et encore faut-il s'entendre sur
ce qu'on entend par baisse puisqu'il
s'agit en réalité d'une décélération ou
d'un ralentissement de la hausse ce qui
ne peut être qualifié de baisse en fait
nous sommes dans un nouveau régime
d'inflation et dans ce contexte vous
faites un pari je suis très étonné de
lire dans l'exposé des motifs du
gouvernement qu'il y aurait un repli des
cours mondiaux des matières premières
énergétiques le rapport aussi parle de
baisse des prix de l'énergie c'est la
première
erreur je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
parier sur une baisse du prix des
énergies fossiles la deuxième erreur
c'est de ne pas s'attaquer à la
profitation car le constat tout le monde
le fait dans les rayons quand ça monte
les coûts de production bah ça monte
tout de suite en rayon et quand ça
baisse ça ne baisse pas sur marge sur
profit sur dividendes ont amplifié là
hausse des coûts de production et dans
un état de misère sociale et écologique
nombre de nos concitoyens en portant une
atteinte au droit fondamental à une
alimentation suffisante et saine tout
cela dépend d'une poignée d'oligopole
les mêmes qui étranglent les
agricultrices et les agriculteurs les
mêmes qui mettent 3 milliards d'euros
dans la promotion de la malbouffe alors
vous nous amenez un projet de loi la 16e
loi en disant sur les relations
commerciales nous promettons un progrès
dérisoire durant 6 semaines dans les
supermarchés c'est un aménagement
conjoncturel dont nous redoutons qu'il
ne soit qu'un coup d'épée dans l'eau nos
amendements sur la transparence et la
réglementation des marges ayant été
refusées nous nous opposerons à ce
projet de loi
bien merci Madame Patou y a-t-il une
réaction madame la ministre
non
j'adhère totalement à vos propos de
démarrage sur l'origine de l'inflation
je trouve qu'on le réduit trop
fréquemment à la question de la guerre
en Ukraine et que ça date d'avant
je vais aussi juste non pas brandir mais
voilà parfois un dessin vaut mieux que
des mots c'est la situation de
l'inflation alimentaire aujourd'hui
autant j'ai pu dire vous avez parlé
d'accélération de la hausse mais il me
semble bien que là pour le coup on a
amorcé une baisse quant au cours des
matières premières
je trouve intéressant non Charles député
fonda voilà c'est une baisse enfin ou
alors je
non juste terminé parce que c'est un
débat qu'on aura peut-être un jour et
qui est intéressant sur le substrat
d'inflation dans le contexte de limite
fini et de géopolitique tendue c'est un
sujet
je vous remercie en 10 secondes monsieur
le rapporteur très rapidement non nous
ne promettons rien nous observons des
baisses de matière première nous
consultons nous avons consulté
l'ensemble des acteurs qui sont
concernés par ce projet de loi et
aujourd'hui nous proposons une solution
pour apporter du pouvoir d'achat aux
Français s'il se met en avant c'est pas
les promesses c'est du concret merci
beaucoup je vous propose de passer à
Monsieur Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe
GDR c'est à vous
en première lecture ma grand-mère en
lisant rapidement le texte aurait dit ça
mange pas de pain ça casse pas trois
pattes un canard
mais en première lecture seulement parce
que en fait ce texte il fait appel à une
situation extrêmement grave les Français
n'ont plus de cran pour se serrer la
ceinture et la crise de l'inflation se
lit sur les visages des familles
présentes dans nos territoires et je
vous assure que tout cela n'est pas
virtuel et tout cela ne prête pas à
sourire et à cela le rapporteur vient de
résumer votre posture vous contentez de
regarder
l'évolution du cours des matières
premières bon libéraux vous êtes
spectateurs du marché parce que ce texte
alors je parle la ministre je pense
qu'elle est chargée d'un texte vide
d'une mauvaise besanne parce que elle a
du mal à y croire elle-même mais ce
texte ne répond rien rien sur les super
profits rien sur la répartition des
marges rien sur les les dividendes et ce
texte fait l'impasse sur le fait que si
l'on accélère les négociations pour des
agriculteurs qui tirent déjà la langue
enfin vous imaginez chez moi les
producteurs de lait chaque jour il y a
un atelier de ferme qui met la clé sous
la porte 800 vaches dans ma
circonscription en moins en six mois 850
000 depuis 2017 depuis que vous êtes
responsabilités l'agriculture est en
train de mourir les prix rémunérateurs
ne sont pas au rendez-vous c'était d'une
certaine manière un aveu d'échec pour
les lois et Gallim 1 2 3 même si elles
étaient dans leur principe généreux et
et et et et accepter mais en tout cas
vous les mettez pas en œuvre vous les
mettez pas en off parce que vous refusez
au bout du compte de répondre à ce qui
aurait dû être au cœur d'une politique
de lutte pour l'inflation l'indexation
des pensions et des salaires sur
l'inflation le blocage de certains prix
de première de produits de première
nécessité pour éviter y compris que les
plus pauvres d'entre nous mangent de
l'alimentation la plus mauvaise possible
pour leur santé je regarde
[Musique]
ceux qui assurent la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays
sont en train de s'essouffler faute de
pré-rémérateur et les habitants
qui se lèvent le matin pour aller bosser
et qui se couche le soir en se disant
qu'ils n'ont pas eu la possibilité de
nourrir leur famille c'est ça à quoi
nous sommes confrontés je vous remercie
pas de réaction je vous propose de
passer donc à l'orateur final qui est
donc Monsieur David topiak pour le
groupe lot c'est à vous merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues là où se
déplie de l'alimentaire atteint 18% en
deux hommes derrière ce chiffre il
pharaon il y a des caddy dans rempli des
renoncements aux produits de qualité
notamment bio et pour certaines
concitoyens des repas sautés face à
cette crise du pouvoir d'achat que
propose le gouvernement difficile de ne
pas évoquer l'autorisation de vente
perte du carburant cette fausse bonne
idée finalement écartée
pour le reste nous sommes face à un
ensemble de mesures peu contraignantes à
l'effet limitée premier exemple le
trimestre anti-inflation dont l'impact
sur les prix est résiduels comme le
relève l'UFC Que Choisir autre mesure
mise en avant par le gouvernement les
aides financières pour les plus modestes
rappelons tout de même qu'elle se
réduisent au minimum les bénéficiaires
du chèque alimentaire seront moins
nombreux cette année que l'année
dernière et son versement n'étant pas
automatique le risque de non recours est
important dernière idée en date et
l'objet de nos discussions d'aujourd'hui
avancer les négociations commerciales au
15 janvier 2024 au lieu du 1er mars vous
espérez ainsi que la baisse des cours de
certaines matières premières se traduira
par une diminution des prix dans les
rayons
nous considérons pour notre part que
c'est un coup de poker sans garantie de
résultats il est vrai que certaines
matières premières voient leur prix
baisser mais combien d'autres continuent
d'augmenter qui peut garantir que la
grande distribution remportera son
rapport de force phrase au grand
industriels nous sommes face à un
scénario multiples inconnu et à l'issue
incertaine une chose à revancher sur un
avancer les négociations commerciales
des plus grands groupes vous pénalisez
les plus petits acteurs le rapport le
rapporteur propose désormais d'asseoir
tout le monde à la table des
négociations au même moment c'est mieux
mais les PME auront-elles seulement les
moyens humains matériels de faire face à
ces négociations commerciales précoces
vous l'aurez compris ce texte pose
autant de questions qui n'apporte de
réponse difficile dans ces conditions de
lui apporter notre soutien
merci beaucoup je propose de couper le
micro merci beaucoup je n'ai terminé
donc pour les orateurs de groupe j'ai
des interventions individuelles de
députés
je vous dis qui j'ai Grigor de fonda
Julien dive Jean-Pierre Vigier Richard
amoz David tobiac non ça évite exprimé
Pascal Lavergne y a-t-il d'autres
demandes individuelles je vous
on a même regardé il y a des inscrits à
l'article on n'est pas du tout au vote
de l'article
ben on va on va avancer monsieur
jumelles comme on fait d'habitude mais
là regardez l'article 10 c'est même pas
commencé il y a des orateurs qui sont
inscrits donc là vraiment vous avez le
temps
et puis il faut qu'on avance un peu
parce que sinon on va on va y passer la
nuit donc je vous propose donc allez-y
voilà donc lever la main pour ceux qui
veulent s'inscrire on commence tout de
suite donc c'est une minute par
intervention monsieur de Fornas on
commence tout de suite avec vous
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais rapidement quand même revenir
sur le graphique madame la ministre vous
a présenté parce que je crois que dans
l'étude de ce texte il va falloir quand
même avoir un souci de vérité la
ministre graphique que vous avez
présenté c'est l'évolution de
l'inflation
alimentaire si l'inflation diminue
madame la ministre il y a toujours une
inflation il y a toujours une
augmentation ce qui veut bien dire vous
avez dit non tout à l'heure ce qui vient
dire qu'il y a une baisse de la hausse
des prix voilà que pour qu'on soit quand
même exacte ça augmente moins mais ça
augmente toujours madame la ministre sur
le puisqu'il me reste 30 secondes je
voudrais qu'on revienne ce quand même
sur sur la déclaration de Thierry Benoît
qui était très intéressantes il a parlé
de TVA social ce qui revient peu au
proue à valider ce que nous nous
défendons sur la baisse de la TVA à 0%
sur un panier de 100 produits de
première nécessité moi ce que je
voudrais parce que le gouvernement a
déjà refusé un rapport sur le sur le
sujet c'est que puisqu'il y a quand même
une partie de la majorité qui qui pousse
cette idée aussi qu'on soit un peu
ouvert d'esprit dans l'étude de ce texte
et qu'on puisse envisager cette mesure
qui par ailleurs a été reconduite merci
en Espagne au Portugal ce qui prouve
qu'elle a une utilité je vous remercie
monsieur div merci monsieur le Président
pardon madame la ministre pas contre
vous mais moi ce débat me désole presque
honte même de se battre pour grappiller
six semaines c'est pas vraiment c'est
pas contre vous je sais bien qu'on en
est là parce que en 5 ans on a légiférer
trois fois et gallima 1 2 3 ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure et encore notre
collègue bateau rappelait même en disant
le nombre de fois aujourd'hui on vient
légiférer pour grappiller 6 semaines on
parle de loi d'exception alors que
faisons-nous l'année prochaine si
l'inflation est au même niveau si elle
est pire est-ce qu'on refait une loi
d'exception et que se passe-t-il le 16
janvier s'il y a des hausses vous pouvez
pas le garantir qu'il y aura des baisses
même si vous avez raison au départ d'une
négociation commerciale on fait une
demande à la hausse pour essayer d'aller
à la baisse mais s'il n'y a pas de
baisse il n'y a pas de baisse on fait
quoi on aura fait une loi on aura
mobilisé d'énergie pour rien je crois
véritablement qu'il faut vraiment se
poser la question à l'avenir peut-être
qu'on l'aura au travers des débats tout
à l'heure d'une vraie réforme sur les
relations commerciales vous n'avez pas
pu le faire là je l'entends mais
vraiment c'est prendre date
merci beaucoup je propose de passer à
Monsieur Mathias Tavel c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre effectivement vous nous
présentez un texte qui est très
franchement et très pauvre alors ce
n'est pas Bruno demande mais ce serait
peut-être Olivia supply supplie que la
négociation entre industrielle et grande
distribution plus aboutir à autre chose
que la hausse des prix alors que
l'exemple nous a été donné quand même
depuis de nombreux mois que c'est la
hausse des prix qui est à chaque fois le
résultat vous êtes devant une situation
où la moitié de la hausse des prix
alimentaires vient des profits de
l'agroalimentaire et vous n'en dites
rien dans ce projet de loi
48,5 % de taux de marge pour cet
industrie au moment où un grand nombre
de nos concitoyens ne parviennent même
plus à acheter de quoi nourrir leurs
enfants et vous êtes là à regarder à
espérer qu'en avançant de six semaines
une négociation entre deux acteurs
privés la situation puisse s'améliorer
mais quand l'État va-t-il enfin faire
son devoir quand l'État va-t-il enfin
permettre à tous les français de manger
à leur fin quand allez-vous enfin
arrêter de vous défausser de vos
responsabilités et taxer c'est super
profit merci je vous propose de passer à
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Vigier
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur depuis
plusieurs mois nous constatons une
baisse de la hausse des prix des
matières premières comme le précise très
bien mon collègue de Fournas mais je
crois que c'est important à travers ce
texte de faire bénéficier les
consommateurs le plus rapidement
possible et cette baisse et cette
loiable mais les résultats attendus de
ce projet de loi sont loin d'être
garanties ce texte fait craindre une
pression tarifaire supplémentaire sur
les produits agricoles et nouvelle
menace sur les équilibres des relations
commerciales alors que la production
agricole et vous le savez demeure
confronté à une augmentation de ses
charges la priorité et de garantir et je
le dis aux effort une transparence des
marges et surtout une juste
redistribution de celle-ci comme cela
est prévu dans l'application des lois et
Galim et de groseilles aussi pouvez-vous
nous assurer que ce texte ne fera pas
des agriculteurs encore une fois la
variable d'ajustement des politiques de
lutte contre l'inflation merci beaucoup
grand merci merci je propose de passer à
Monsieur Richard Amos c'est à vous
le rapporteur madame la ministre je
voulais vous dire que j'ai hôte estime
du travail que vous faites pour nos PME
je vais pas commenter ce qui est pas
dans le texte mais ce qui est dans le
texte moi je suis très inquiet quand
avec monsieur le rapporteur vous nous
dites la grande distribution finalement
est venue nous dire qu'elle obtiendrait
des baisses ça veut dire quoi qu'elle va
être anglais encore plus que d'habitude
comme elle le fait dans le bac des
négociations ça veut dire que pour vous
être agréable elle va encore saigner nos
paysans elle va soigner nos PME et
peut-être que les gros gros industriels
eux pourront Diller avec eux c'est ça
qui m'inquiète ce qui m'inquiète dans ce
texte là c'est qu'à la fin nous n'aurons
pas de baisse et que les six semaines
que nous aurons gagnées ce sera six
semaines à la fin de hausse pôle
consommateurs je le dis comme je le
pense comme d'habitude je ne crois pas
qu'on aura des baisses à la fin si j'ai
tort et bien évidemment ça aura ça vous
aura donné raison dans ce pari là moi je
pense que si demain on a des baisses
c'est qu'on aura saigné nos paysans et
nos PME et si on a des hausses on aura
voté un texte qui aurait été contre le
consommateur
merci beaucoup madame Aurélie trouver
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues
prendre les propos de mes collègues de
la nupes ou de l'autre je vais reprendre
les propos du collègue d'Yves parce que
je partage entièrement ce projet de loi
est absolument désolant il a inutile
mais même je dirais dangereux et vous
venez nous dire Madame la Ministre tout
à l'heure si l'écoute de production
baisse je cite c'est naturel que les
prix des produits alimentaires en rayon
baisse mais alors là c'est vraiment
symptomatique de votre foie illimité et
peut-être aussi de votre méconnaissance
du marché et au fond surtout de votre
impuissance totale face aux
multinationales ce qui a rien qui va
dans ce que vous dites d'abord il y a
aucune baisse des prix de l'énergie qui
est prévue dans les prochains mois bien
au contraire et ça ça constitue vous le
savez quand même le gros des coûts de
production dans ces conditions il est
très improbable que les coûts de
production des industriels reculent ça
c'est la première chose et même s'il a
par miracle ses coûts de production BC
et ben je vais vous apprendre une chose
il y a ce qu'on appelle les marges les
marges des grands industriels
agroalimentaires et comme vous ne faites
rien pour ne serait-ce qu'encadrer ou
limité leur position ultra dominante sur
les marchés qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire
comme ils font depuis plusieurs mois et
bien ils augmenteront leur marge et donc
les prises alimentaires merci beaucoup
la parole est au président André chassen
c'est à vous
oui tout simplement pour vous dire que
c'est vrai que le gouvernement demande
moi je préfère le mot Clément d'ailleurs
madame la ministre et pendant ce temps
je dirais que la grande distribution
c'est beau dit elle rigole la grande
distribution parce qu'elle a très peu
elle a vraiment très très peur de cette
loi parce que dans le même temps elle
continue à jouer sur les marques de
distribution en jouant sur le sur les
volumes elle continue par des contacts
directs à faire ce qu'on appelle du
destratage c'est à dire faire pression
sur le fournisseur pour qu'on ne
retrouve plus le produit un rayon elle
continue par différents artifices en
faisant des stockages stratégiques avec
des achats en promo et prouvant d'eau
prix fort elle continue avec des
pratiques qui sont illégales à une
ribambelle de service qui sont demandées
aux fournisseurs qui et qui en
définitive ne servent pas à faire la
promotion du produit mais avoir des
emplois déguisés tout ça je crois qu'il
s'agit encore de cadeaux déguisés en
plus de ceci qui sont à la grande
distribution c'est aucun effet et sur
les effets catastrophiques notamment
pour nos agriculteurs
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Monsieur David topiac pour l'iode
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
faire un focus particulier sur la sur
les filières biologiques et notamment le
la crise inflationniste qui a mené une
difficulté sur le pouvoir d'achat il est
consommateurs se sont déportés des
produits bio de manière assez massive
pour s'orienter plus vers des produits
de premier prix on a une difficulté
aujourd'hui la répercussion sur
l'industrie roulementaire plutôt de
petites industries valorisent nos
productions locales qui a une grosse
baisse évidemment dans ses ventes qui se
retrouve également percuté pour un prix
de l'énergie qui continue d'augmenter
j'ai entendu tout ça qu'on parlait de
baisse je confirme que le prix d'énergie
contient augmenté que nous sommes alerté
tous les jours sur le terrain derrière
l'agriculture bio qui engrave difficulté
avec des menaces de décoration assez
massives dans mon département du Gers
qui est le premier département bio de
France un exemple le blé un accord de
blé bio nous étions à 110 euros au début
de la campagne nous sommes contre 220
euros pour le conventionnel il y a une
vraie crise dont je demande
effectivement qu'on mette en place un
plan de soutien pour le bio avant
d'envisager ce programme parce qu'il y a
une réelle difficulté et dans le plan il
ne s'agit pas seulement d'un soutien qui
va falloir réaffirmer mais il s'agit
aussi d'aide aux déclassement merci
la parole est à Monsieur
Damien Maudet pour elle et fille
merci monsieur le Président bon c'est de
la croyance on aurait peut-être gagné
beaucoup plus de temps si on avait tout
simplement allumé un cierge en vérité
ici il y a aucune remise en cause des
règles c'est une croyance folle en la
main invisible du marché en fait c'est
la même croyance folle que nous suivons
depuis des dizaines d'années dans un
premier temps nous avaient poussé à
délocaliser tout l'outil industriel et
maintenant cette croyance folle qui nous
pousse à laisser les entreprises et les
dans l'agroalimentaire de faire flamber
les prix c'est la même croyance folk
comme l'a dit le Cholet Grammos a non
seulement appauvri les consommateurs
mais risque même d'appauvrir encore les
producteurs en vérité c'est le fond où
le terrain international qui explique
que 50% de la hausse des prix est due au
profit donc si vous voulez agir sur la
hausse des prix attaquez-vous tout
simplement au profit je sais pas moi
bloquer les prix attaquer vos marges et
puis si vous voulez donner un peu de
pouvoir d'achat indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation vous voyez bien qu'on n'est
pas à la hauteur ou alors à la limite
enlever enlever urgence de votre de du
titre de cette proposition de loi il
mettait plutôt pour voir on verra bien
croyance peut-être à mesure pour la
croyance merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Pascal Lavergne merci monsieur
le Président je voudrais d'abord
remercier mes collègues qui dans leurs
propos après votre intervention madame
la ministre ont mis un terme aux
angoisses qui étaient les miennes
puisque j'avoue que le propos liminaire
qui existe dans l'exposé les motifs et
également dans votre propos liminaire
concernant le constat de la de la baisse
du prix des matières premières agricoles
m'inquiéter un peu parce que moi je ne
me réjouis pas pour les agriculteurs de
la baisse
du prix des productions agricoles parce
que tout simplement ils ne vont pas avec
ces baisses de produits pouvoir
continuer à exister demain donc il
faudra un moment donné peut-être aller
vers des systèmes de contractualisation
comme la proposition collect potier mais
ce n'est pas l'objet de ce texte mais en
tout cas merci de tenir compte de ça et
je remercie mes collègues d'avoir
rectifié un petit peu et partager les
inquiétudes dont je leur ai fait part en
début d'après-midi sur sur cette
problématique de la rémunération des
agriculteurs
merci je me suis Nicolas maisonnet merci
Monsieur président simplement une
question absolument rapporteur tout à
l'heure vous avez dit que si l'on baissé
ou supprimer la TVA sur des produits de
première nécessité il n'était pas
évident que en gros que la grande
distribution la répercut sur le prix
final
qu'est-ce qui vous garantit que si les
distributeurs obtiennent des baisses de
prix auprès des fournisseurs ils les
répercuteront auprès du du consommateur
donc vous voyez que vous voyez vous
voyez bien que si dans cette situation
l'État ne joue pas son rôle de
régulateur n'encadre pas les prix avec
comme on l'a dit un prix
plancher qui protège notre nos
producteurs et nos agriculteurs et un
prix plafond qui empêche les marges
abusives alors on ne peut rien faire
bien y a-t-il d'autres interventions
alors juste parce que ça me fait agir
monsieur maisonnée mais si par exemple
vous avez un acteur de la distribution
Système U qui négociait avec Ferrero et
qui négocie faire un rocher à un certain
prix il est évident que comme on est
dans le système de concurrence si un
autre distributeur obtient auprès de
Ferrero des prix qui sont beaucoup moins
cher si tu as vu à aucune aucun intérêt
à mettre un prix à un niveau qui serait
démesurément supérieur à son voisin
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce qui garantit
la question que vous posez est
intéressante est liée en gros qu'est-ce
qui garantit que 6 obtiennent des
baisses dans les négociations avec les
industriels ils disent pas finalement je
vais pas baisser les prix et je vais
laisser un prix très élevé alors que
j'ai obtenu une baisse auprès des
industrielle bah en fait c'est la
concurrence c'est le fait que derrière
il y a une telle concurrence aujourd'hui
dans le système pardon
écoutez non mais attendez attendez mais
c'est intéressant parce qu'on peut avoir
de beaux débats moi je vous connaissez
ma position personnelle je vois madame
trouvé sur le sujet je ne suis pas un
adepte du blocage des prix si vous
voulez qu'on tire la ficelle du blocage
des prix même des marges on pourrait
prendre des exemples internationaux dans
des pays et dans des économies de marché
ou dans des économies bloquées ou sur
lesquels ça ne fonctionne pas non plus
donc moi je dis juste c'est mon
sentiment personnel c'est que la
concurrence est une façon effectivement
d'obtenir des baisses et que à l'inverse
le bloc HD prix n'en ai pas une mais il
faut avoir ce débat
je sens que j'ai touché une corde
sensible sur le blocage des prix
bien
non mais je ne suis pas un fan du
blocage j'ai pris de l'économie
administrée monsieur monsieur Tavel vous
le savez bien bon je vous propose je ne
sais pas s'il y a une réaction moi
c'était ma réaction personnelle débat
entre blocage des prix baisse de TVA et
qu'est-ce qui garantit que les prix
baisses et ce que la concurrence
fonctionne
excusez-moi monsieur jumelles j'ai le
droit d'avoir une pensée libérale c'est
pas un crime aujourd'hui voilà je peux
l'assumer monsieur le rapporteur
allez-y oui moi très rapidement je
trouve que l'intégralité des
interventions que vous avez faites sont
tout intéressantes mais finalement quand
on les remet tous ensemble elles sont
assez confus parce que j'entends d'un
côté que les prix les tarifs ne
baisseront pas j'entends de l'autre côté
qu'on va saigner nos PME nos agris donc
qui vont finalement être achetés moins
cher si je comprends bien donc d'un côté
les prix vont augmenter de l'autre côté
le même trompe pas j'entends aussi que
l'avancée de six semaines ne change rien
et j'attends après que d'avancer de six
semaines changera tout donc finalement
je trouve que l'ensemble de vos propos
sont assez confus moi ce que je veux
dire ce que je veux dire ce que je veux
dire pour pour conclure ça ce que je
veux dire pour conclure ça c'est que si
avec cette proposition on a une chance
de faire baisser les prix avec 6
semaines d'avance c'est-à-dire de donner
aux Français six semaines de pouvoir
d'achat moi je crois qu'on peut mettre
toute notre énergie dedans et moi
personnellement je la mets de bon cœur
bien Madame le Ministre une réaction
avant qu'on commence les amendements
bien
bon on va voir le temps de discuter à
l'occasion de tous les amendements que
vous souhaitez donc on va commencer
directement dans les amendements et
comme d'habitude je prendrai un pour un
compte et si je sens que tous les
groupes veulent intervenir on ouvrira en
fonction de la discussion je pense qu'on
peut vu la masse d'amendement terminé
pour 20h on peut se donner une petite
extension à 20h30
sinon bah on revient à 21h30 chers
collègues
moi j'adore débattre je voulais passer
de la nuit à débattre pas de problème
donc on commence tout de suite si vous
en êtes d'accord avec un amendement de
suppression de l'article 41 qui est
présenté par Madame trouvé madame trouvé
vous allez la parole
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues on vous demande de supprimer
l'article unique de ce projet de loi
parce que pour tout dire ce projet de
loi est absolument inapte et fait perdre
un temps vital pour un grand nombre de
Français qui souffrent de la fin déjà
mais surtout pire ce projet de loi va
peut-être offrir aux grands industriels
de l'agroalimentaire de pouvoir avancer
et accélérer la hausse de leur prix de
leur marge c'est sans doute un bravo le
premier projet de loi de l'histoire de
France a accélérer la hausse des prix
alimentaires j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est pharaon moi je sais pas où vous
avez trouvé que les prix imposés par les
grands industriels allez diminuer comme
par magie dans les prochaines semaines
j'ai beau chercher je vois pas les
industriels vous disent le contraire
l'Insee dit le contraire je cite
Emmanuel Kahn de l'Institut Nielson qui
dit qu'avec ce projet de loi on va
peut-être arriver à laisser inverse à
celui escompté si les os l'emportent sur
les baisses mais alors vous qu'est-ce
que vous faites vous persistez vous
signez vous avancez quand même la date
des négociations et en plus vous allez
nous faire croire que c'est utile aux
Français et franchement je vois pas un
seul économie sérieux en France qui
pourrait accepter de défendre votre
projet de loi absurde alors pourquoi je
récapitule qu'est-ce je sais que les
prix des grands industriels peuvent
augmenter dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois un les coups de
production on sait que les coûts de
l'énergie vont probablement stagner ou
augmenter donc évidemment ça a augmenté
les coûts de production des industriels
en tout cas ils vont pas baisser 2 les
marges des grands industries à
l'agroalimentaire puisque c'est elle qui
alimente essentiellement la hausse des
prix alimentaires et comme vous ne
faites rien absolument rien pour réguler
ses marges et ben elles ont déjà été
multipliées par plus de deux en un an et
demi et elles vont continuer évidemment
à augmenter donc je récapitule hausse
des coûts de production des industriels
sinon stagnation
os démarche des grands industriels
agroalimentaires ça donne quoi ça donne
une augmentation des prix alimentaires
proposés par les grands industriels à la
grande distribution donc en somme votre
texte il est non seulement inutile mais
il est sans doute dangereux pour nos
concitoyens et donc nous vous proposons
d'en supprimer l'UNIC article
merci monsieur le rapporteur quel est
votre avis
allez-y c'est bon ouais c'est bon alors
le rapporteur est à la fois défavorable
à cet amendement et défavorable au
discours que je viens d'entendre parce
que si je vous écoute la majorité ne
fait rien je vais pas vous rappeler tout
ce qu'on a déjà dit dans nos discours
liminaires avec la ministre mais je vais
vous rappeler très rapidement quand même
le bouclier tarifaire 50 milliards qui
ont été mis pour protéger les Français
je vais vous rappeler les aides
exceptionnelles de rentrer la
revalorisation des aPL des minima
sociaux des retraites je l'ai déjà fait
dans mon propos liminaire donc
premièrement vous ne pouvez pas nous
expliquer que la majorité ne fait rien
pour les Français ensuite si je vous
écoute l'intégralité des prix vont
augmenter alors dans ce cas ça répond
aux autres problématiques qui vont être
soulevées du fait que les industriels
les acteurs de l'agroalimentaire vont
voir leur rémunération baissée ça va
totalement à l'encontre l'un avec
l'autre moi très sincèrement je vais
vous dire exactement la même chose que
ce que je viens de dire juste avant
c'est que si en l'état vous estimez que
tout faire pour faire gagner 6 semaines
de pouvoir d'achat aux Français et vins
dans ce cas là effectivement nous ne
sommes pas d'accord
madame la ministre
j'aurai le même avis que le rapporteur
sans vous étonner un avis défavorable et
j'entends bien vos propositions je
reviendrai pas surtout mais citez-moi un
seul pays européen
qui est bloqué les prix de l'alimentaire
citez-moi un seul pays européen
or Hongrie ou le blocage les prix madame
la députée est fonctionné
il y en a aucun il y en a aucun il y en
a même on pourrait prendre l'exemple de
l'Argentine avec le blocage des prix de
la viande qui fait que du coup les quand
on leur a dit on bloque les prix de la
viande
au début ils ont commencé à faire que de
l'export parce que les prix étaient
libérés quand on leur a dit on bloque
l'export et vous devez vendre uniquement
sur le marché argentin si ils ont mis de
la graisse à l'intérieur des paquets de
viande en disant qu'on nous a administré
un prix qui est bloqué on est obligé de
mettre pardon mais une horreur à
l'intérieur pour pouvoir se conformer au
prix donc ça n'a pas marché ça crée ça
met toujours le blocage des prix de
toute façon c'est systématique c'est
dans tous les pays c'est immédiatement
pénurie
arrêt de la production pénurie marcher
parallèle marcher au noir ou en fait
vous négociez sous le manteau et le jour
où vous libérez les prix tout explose
bien évidemment dans un effet de
rattrapage mais ça c'est dans tous les
pays dans toutes les économies du monde
qu'elles soient de marché ou des
économies administrées c'est
systématiquement le même effet mais
c'est fascinant que ça soit encore une
solution miracle j'ai plusieurs demandes
de prise de parole j'ai deux options
pour ou enfin pour un compte ou alors
sinon je joue à chacun des groupes parce
que là j'ai trois demandes potiers
jumelles et Tavel vous défendez alors
écoutez c'est un amendement de
suppression on va on va faire quelque
chose on va faire une intervention par
groupe comme ça shaggo pourra s'exprimer
donc je vais prendre pour le groupe
socialiste petit monsieur petit c'était
vous oui on a encore dans les avec cette
demande
d'annulation des article premier donc de
la loi tu as un peu dans les propos
liminaires on se chauffe et vous avez
pris beaucoup de temps monsieur le
Président pour dénoncer le blocage des
prix et la régulation autoritaire
administrative des prix je crois quand
même vous contredire sur l'illusion la
fiction libérale que vous entretenez sur
la libre concurrence non mais tout de
même
ça veut dire on a très clairement une
oligarchie au niveau de l'achat tout le
monde le dit enfin tout me l'a constaté
tous les rapports le confirme etc et
d'autre part on a quelques utilisations
dans le qui détiennent des marques dont
la force dans l'imaginaire dans la
servitude marchande auprès de nos
concitoyens font que ils imposent ils
imposent leur mise en rayon avec les
prix qui les imposent également donc il
y a pas de libre concurrence la vraie
solution et vous le savez vous devriez
au moins l'admettre c'est une régulation
des prix avec un contrôle des super
profits une transparence pour les
consommateurs autant de propositions qui
pour l'instant n'ont pas été acceptées
par la majorité mais sortons de ce débat
caricatural entre le blocage des prix et
une concurrence loyale elle n'existe pas
aujourd'hui surtout que là le projet de
loi c'est pas le blocage des prix c'est
un avancement de six semaines des négo
mais pour un peu monsieur Tavel c'est à
vous
merci monsieur le Président si vous
espérez baisser les prix en 6 semaines
il y a quelque chose qui durcitent
semaines et qui baisse les prix ça
s'appelle les soldes et c'est au moins
plus efficace que la négociation que
vous prétendez avancer mais si vous nous
présentez ce texte et vos réponses ou
même si vous y mettez à 3
le monde c'est que vous n'avez vous
refusez de voir une réalité vous nous
dites vous pouvez pas à la fois dire que
la négociation va faire augmenter les
prix et étouffer les producteurs mais si
justement c'est qu'entre le prix que
paye le consommateur et le prix qui est
payé au producteur il y a quelque chose
que vous refusez de voir qui s'appelle
les marges les profits et c'est là
dessus qu'il y a du gras à prendre si
j'ose dire pour baisser les prix et
permettre aux Français de se nourrir si
vous refusez de vous attaquer au profit
et aux marges alors forcément vous
n'avez pas d'autre choix que d'implorer
le dieu concurrence mais qui ne marchera
pas il faut bloquer les marges et
bloquer les prix parce qu'en fin sur la
concurrence vous nous dites que le
blocage des prix ne marche pas moi ce
que je constate c'est que ça n'a pas été
fait dans notre pays sauf récemment une
fois sur le gel hydroalcoolique et que
ça a marché et que par contre la libre
concurrence on l'a sous les yeux et
c'est plus 20% sur les prix de
l'alimentation depuis deux ans donc ayez
au moins l'honnêteté de reconnaître que
votre système ne marche pas et d'essayer
celui que vous-même vous aviez mis en
place au moment de la crise covid le
blocage des prix pour le gel hydroal
pardon et qui marche outre-mer au
demeurant merci beaucoup monsieur de
Fornas
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
notre collègue t'avais la rappeler vous
avez une position très très dogmatique
sur la question de blocage des prix que
nous pour nous notre part on ne défend
pas on encadre on défend l'encadrement
des marges ce qui est différent mais
enfin ça a été rappelé le gouvernement
que vous soutenez afin de blocage j'ai
pris sur alcoolique j'avais l'occasion
de vous le rappeler en séance lors de
chez colo le blocage des prix a été mis
en place en 76 sous un gouvernement qui
était quand même proche politiquement du
vôtre c'est sous le Giscard d'Estaing et
qui a été terminé par un gouvernement
très libéral qui était celui de
Mitterrand vous voyez donc c'était c'est
c'est quand même un peu plus compliqué
que ce que voulait dire nous ce qu'on
défend c'est l'encadrement des marges ou
en d'autres termes le pacte de
modération des marges qui a été défendu
par le Président de la République non il
y a pas il y a quelques jours mais qui
n'est pas dans ce texte de loi vous
voyez ça c'est encore une annonce un peu
bricolé sur le coin d'une table avec
quand même des convictions aléatoires
mais qu'on ne retrouve pas de façon
pratique dans le dans la loi alors c'est
ce qu'on c'est ce que nous on va on va
défendre et je voudrais terminer non
merci on a qu'une minute bon super merci
beaucoup monsieur il y aura d'autres
occasions vous pourrez défendre le
blocage des prix avec le rassemblement
national monsieur de fournaise monsieur
decrozeilles c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président
de quoi est-ce qu'on parle en fait on
parle juste de date donc tout revient
tous les débats qu'on a eu sur
l'encadrement des marges etc là il
s'agit juste en fait on se prend la
question de la date annuelle parce que
depuis deux ans la volatilité des cours
des matières premières et donc des prix
est parfaitement inédite on n'avait pas
connu ça depuis plus de 15 ans donc là
ben moi ce que je propose c'est qu'on
concentre les débats sur la question de
cette date il s'agit d'avancer tout
simplement pour rapprocher les prix à la
vente de ce qui se passe en amont et
reprenons au calme à je ne sais quelle
occasion mais il nous appartient de nous
saisir de l'ensemble de la loi
chers collègues j'ai revenu riz vous
aviez dit à l'époque est-ce qu'il y aura
Gallim 4 mais on va pas l'appeler
Galline 4 cette fois mais on était
d'accord pour dire qu'en fait on n'a pas
fini d'en parler de cette question de
négociations commerciales donc on va en
reparler on peut peut-être nettoyer le
texte dans lequel il y a plein de
scories réglementaires se redire quels
sont les grands principes de loi qui
font l'ordre public économique et se
reposer la question de cette date
annuelle sans avoir de révision en
avance mais là concentrons-nous sur
l'objet merci beaucoup y a-t-il d'autres
groupes qui souhaitent s'intervenir
monsieur Ramos pour le modem oui
monsieur le Président moi je suis pas
pour la fixation des prix mais il faut
faire attention quand on veut obtenir
des prix bas on a eu la gruge sur les
emballages et je le dis on aura la gruge
à la fois sur la composition des
produits ça a démarré et on aura la
gruge également sur les origines quand
vous allez dans les rayons de Monsieur
Leclerc en ce moment vous avez du beurre
doux qui vient d'Irlande avec du lait
qui vient d'Irlande alors qu'il nous
fait la leçon et donc attention c'était
pas parce que demain vous n'aurez pas la
fixation des prix que vous n'aurez pas
la grue je la composition et la gruge
sur les origines c'est ce que fait
monsieur Leclerc en trichant mais tendu
les demi-écrémé qui n'est pas
demi-écrémé et en mettant du beurre qui
vient d'Irlande bien y a-t-il d'autres
groupes qui souhaitent s'exprimer non
pas de commentaire supplémentaires
rapporteur et gouvernement je vous
propose donc de passer au vote sur cet
amendement de suppression et ensuite un
double avis défavorable rapporteur et
ministre qui est pour la suppression
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté amendement pouvant
être soumis à une discussion commune
amendement identique monsieur le
rapporteur vous nous proposez le 78
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
c'est amendement il vise tout simplement
à retirer le seuil de 150 millions
d'euros afin de soumettre l'intégralité
des entreprises à la date du 15 janvier
je l'ai explosé dans mon propos
introductif ce cette proposition elle
vise simplement à mettre tout le monde
sur un pied d'égalité sachant que les
PME ont l'habitude de signer avant le 31
12 et certains voudraient qu'on mette
dans la loi justement cette date du 31
12 qui me paraît un peu restreint ce que
je propose c'est que toutes les PME qui
n'auront pas la possibilité de signer
fin décembre puisse par cette mesure ne
pas être reléguée après la date du 15
janvier soit traitée comme les autres
acteurs c'est simplement l'objet de mon
propos
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
j'ai un identique de Monsieur jumelles
le numéro 7 monsieur Chasset Monsieur
William je ne le vois pas donc il n'est
pas défendu j'ai madame Babeau qui nous
propose un identique le 58
rapporteur c'est le minimum il faut que
les PME et ETI sont alignés aux
multinationales au minimum merci
beaucoup madame Bazin propose le 71
non soutenu donc ça c'était les
amendements qui étaient identiques mais
nous avons une discussion commune et
nous continuons donc avec le 18 de
Monsieur Nury oui merci monsieur le
Président donc oui nous avons très très
peur de cette distorsion de concurrence
entre les grands groupes et les PME et
les ETI et le fait que les grands
groupes puissent négocier avant les PME
nous paraît dangereux pour ces PME qui
sont souvent d'ailleurs très présentes
en termes d'emploi sur nos territoires
et sur nos territoires ruraux et donc ce
qu'on voudrait c'est leur donner un
temps d'avance par rapport aux autres et
donc de pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il
puisse en gros dès qu'ils sont à moins
de 150 millions voire négocier pour le
15 janvier pour les autres qui sont à
plus de 150 millions ou 31 janvier c'est
15 jours d'avance paraissent peut-être
pas beaucoup
mais ça leur permet d'être d'abord si on
peut dire plus rapidement dans les
négociations commerciales sur tout ce
qui est promotion tout ce qui est
également mis en avant des produits et
ça nous paraît indispensable que cette
loi de manière globale qui va qui part
d'une bonne intention ne soit pas pire
que le statut quo pour CPME une fois
encore qui sont fragiles donc cet
amendement là c'est c'est va dans ce
sens en tout cas
je vous remercie monsieur Nury nous
allons passer dans la discussion commune
est-ce qu'on peut considérer que le 25
vous l'avez le 25 et le 10 qui suivez
vous l'avez défendu vous souhaitez avoir
une intervention différente juste en
fait on est sur des seuils qui sont
différents puisque en fait on est sur
350 millions d'euros qui est le seuil
qui retenu par l'Union européenne pour
considérer qu'on est sur une PME ti donc
après là on est sur 31 décembre pour les
moins 350 millions d'euros et 15 janvier
pour les plus de 350 millions d'euros
l'amendement suivant puisqu'on le ce10
alors il y a le il y a le 18 que vous
avez défendu le 25 et le 10 vous en avez
trois donc l'autre c'est les moins 150
millions d'euros 31 décembre plus 150
millions d'euros 15 janvier et ensuite
et puis voilà c'est tout d'accord merci
beaucoup madame Blin n'est pas défendu
et Monsieur Nuri vous aviez le 20
également alors le 20 c'est toujours par
rapport au seuil et par rapport aux
dates donc 350 millions d'euros en
dessous on est au 15 janvier et au
dessus de 350 millions d'euros au 31
janvier vous voyez chaque fois c'était
la même philosophie avec les 150
millions les 350 millions et sur les 15
jours d'avance pour les PME et